[Music]  isolation is used for a person that is  ill and being confined to their home or  other location to prevent the spread of  infection people who have been diagnosed  with coronavirus disease kovat 19 that  are well enough to go home are placed on  isolation and should monitor for  worsening of the disease these are  patients that may just have a fever  runny nose or slight cough patients on  isolation for kovat 19:00 should be  monitored for concerning symptoms  including rapid progression of their  symptoms or difficulty breathing if  someone has these symptoms while on  isolation they should seek medical  attention and make certain that they  notify others that they are on isolation  for kovat 19  [Music]